.
IN THE AMERICAN SOMEDISTILLERIE.
CNN' MIGUEL MAREZ SWS
HOW.ep TSST HND TO ACE
SURVIVOR, SAW ANOTHERD THAI ING.
WE CAN TAKE THAT ALCOHOL ANDDDS
PEOPLE ARENOF. RCE GROUP NEEDEDP
IN THIS  A TIMEAT WIN, NOT A FOM
OF AND OF PURPE. THEY STOPPED M
CR THE SANITIZER.
>> WE'RE LERG WHAT G BOURBAND T
A VERY PROOFIN
L ADD INGREDIENTS LIKE T MAKE
VISCUOUS ON HANDS A A F
THAT TLTON'S RE
THE ALCOHOL IS THE HAR PAEY KNO.
>> Reporter:TLATER,
THE FIRST BAH, ONLY LETS WAY MO
CAN FILL.
THEY WERENRATE FENTT>> TISTOCK .
WE HAD A AND LOTION
BUSINESSHE EMPLOYED >> Repte THL
SHE OAK HHAT  STAGLL FOR
FREE.
AT DOES TS WHATVE TO DO THE LAS
KEEP ETH>> Reporter: SHE'S NOW
UPTHE ARMY OFF
ENTREPRENTSRN OUT.Y IS HE KEEP
EMPLOYEES ING, BUT IFTURNS OUTR'
HAPPENING. NO, WE'RE 100% COMMID
PROVIDING THIS PRODUCTCOMMUNIT.
>> Reporter: CG IN
AENE SCRAW ON A
SSION. HANDANITIZON NEED.
COULDN'T GET ANY
R,  HOW MUC
E NG IT
THEY'RE GING IAY. F
LEN, BUT ADY IT, THEY'RE GIVINGY
FOR  WHATREAT STO